let's just talk uh about the prime
minister's response he's always
vehemently denied that he was involved
personally in the evacuation of animals
and animal shelter workers from
afghanistan his defense has moved from
this is total nonsense to this is total
rhubarb
yeah well he always treats um the public
with disdain doesn't he doesn't come up
with a proper uh denial he comes up with
just these kind of exorbitant phrases
remember years ago there was that one
this is an inverted pyramid of piffle uh
and it turned out in that case that the
inverted the lie was him denying the lie
if you see what i mean
look
the problem for the prime minister is
that the evidence is really now stacking
up in black and white we've got a letter
from
trudy harrison the prime minister's uh
parliamentary private secretary at the
time uh his bag carrier and saying that
she's acting uh on his behalf you've got
emails and from the foreign office
saying that the prime minister has
authorized the evacuation of the animals
and you've got emails saying that the
foreign secretary is going to get
clearance from the prime minister and
you've got or from danny street rather
to be more precise you've got emails
you've got emails showing which i think
news nights have shown um of the of
other foreign office officials making uh
um making it clear that downing street
is engaged in this issue um
you know it just stacks up um and every
single time
the prime minister says that this is
untrue there's just another revelation
that comes around the corner uh he
should come to the house of commons um
in one way
this story doesn't matter
except it really does
because at the time of the evacuation i
like many other mps had hundreds of
names of
british british citizens and relatives
who were and people who'd worked with
the british armed forces in afghanistan
and were therefore very very vulnerable
when the taliban took over and we were
desperate to get those people to safety
um many thousands were left behind
and the the government ran such a
chaotic operation that we're not sure
that they ever prioritized the right
people or even got safe you know got
people to safety who should have been
brought to safety at all
so that's why this matters because we
just need to get to the truth
is it the action or the denial of action
that is angering you would you be
satisfied if the prime minister for
example came out and said look actually
yes i did personally sanction that but
it wasn't using any government resources
the plane was paid for using donations i
just gave it clearance to take off
would that be okay with you or is it the
fact that you think he did this he just
doesn't want to admit it
i think they should all just hold up
their hands and say this is what we did
and this was our judgment we thought
that it was more important to have an
airplane
this airplane landing and supported than
any other airplane and and okay fine i
might disagree with them i might say
look here's a list of 134 people from uh
who are connected to my constituency in
the ronda who some of whom are still in
hiding um in taliban run afghanistan at
the moment and are desperate to get home
um
so i disagree with you but fair enough
you've come you've come clean but the
problem we've got now is either lord
goldsmith's and he's a conservative
member of the house of lords and and
foreign office minister either he and
his office have been lying or trudy
harrison the prime ministers and bag
carrier conservative mp and
parliamentary private secretary is lying
or the prime minister is lying or all
the officials are lying
you know you just have to take your pick
yeah penn farving who runs the animal
charity at the center of all of this and
his own submission to the foreign
affairs committee said let me make it
abundantly clear uh no hmg capacity was
used to transport any animals none mr
fathering said he and his animals did
not enter kabul airport through the gate
controlled by british soldiers he also
said it was american not british
soldiers who helped load animals onto a
flight and that he himself had chartered
paid for donations he also went on to
say that a lot of his staff didn't
actually leave from cardboard airport to
the uk they had to escape into pakistan
so it doesn't sound like they got too
much help
from the british government
well no but but it now looks from these
emails that um that i think you have
that uh
trudy harrison
supposedly on behalf of her boss the
prime minister
was approaching other organizations for
donations to help ben farving
these are the emails to the virgin
atlantic where she said relevant
permissions would be fast-tracked in
government
exactly so i mean
i don't know what that means
if you're if you're writing and
everybody knows that you are the bank
carrier to the prime minister and you're
working down the street then i think
people would assume that the prime
minister is on top of that uh and behind
it that's that's the working assumption
so now it is possible that maybe trudy
who instantly i'd like as a person
um uh
i i but
it's perfectly possible that she was
just overplaying her hand but in which
case she should just say that come out
in public and say i'm really sorry look
i kind of i kind of overstated the case
and i hadn't ever really spoken so how
do we get to the bottom of this is it is
it another investigation i lose track of
how many investigations that have begun
over the last few weeks is that is that
what you want to see
i know look
um i think voters in the country
must be sick to the back teeth of all of
this if i'm honest
um a lot of people have decided that
he's a liar when i went to the rugby
last week in ferndale two weeks ago i
mean basically everybody was saying
boris out boris out boris
i do out
to come back at that i was in
wolverhampton yesterday which is a
conservative seat conservative southwest
and so many people backing the prime
minister and saying
on the bigger decisions he is getting
things right things that affect their
life like helping their business to stay
aflate over the pandora these these
little matters they see as a westminster
thing they don't really see them
affecting them in wolverhampton
well i i i'm not well that's not been my
experience we're gonna have to agree to
um
we're going to have to agree to differ
on that sorry um
we're going to have to agree to differ
on that but the point i was going to
make was i think people really care
about the cost of living crisis the fact
that you know um energy bills are
we've still got you don't worry
yes sorry um i think people really care
about um the cost of living crisis
energy bills going up um you know six
million people on the
on the on waiting list
operations and you know cancer catch-up
and all the rest of it yes those are the
things they really care about they're
worried about what's happening in
ukraine but the problem is that the
prime minister's moral authority is now
so completely and utterly shot that he
cannot lead this country you know the
government's in paralysis he's not he's
not answering he's not leading on um
what's happening in in ukraine um i
think you had a a minister a former
finnish prime minister on earlier today
who just laughed when you asked whether
he's leaving on that and that's because
he's tied up with all of this
and and
i
you may be right that some voters don't
care about it
but
the moment you start saying that voters
don't care about standards in public
life that is just an excuse for bad
behavior okay chris bryant on that note
we'll leave it there thank you so much
for coming on here to sky news this
afternoon really appreciate your time